I worked with this crazy psychologist,
he,
he used to put jokes on is multiple
choice tests.
He was a really eccentric guy,
but I really liked his courses.
He and he,
he taught a course on creativity and he
was also a prison psychologist and he
was an eccentric guy and he for some
reason liked me and maybe because I was
eccentric to and he invited me to go out
to the Edmonton maximum security prison
with them a couple of times,
which I did.
And that was a very interesting
experience because I was trying to
figure out what role each individual's
behavior bore to the pathology of the
group with something like that.
And I went out there and I met with the
little guy smaller than me.
I was a little bigger by then and he was
a pretty innocuous guy.
And uh,
what had happened was I was out in this
gymnasium,
it looks like a high school.
The prison,
which is really quite telling in my
estimation,
but,
and there were all these like monsters
in their weightlifting and like they
were monsters.
I remember one guy who was tattooed
everywhere and he had like a huge scar
running down the middle of his chest.
It looked like someone had to hit them
with an ax and you know,
and,
and I was in there and I had this Weird
Cape that I used to wear that I bought
in Portugal and some boots that went
along with it.
Yeah,
it was like an 1890 sherlock Holmes Cape
and it was really like,
it was from the 18 nineties because this
little village was up on a hill.
It was a walled city on a hill and they
sold these things and I don't think
they've changed the style since 1890.
And so I thought they were really cool
and so I was wearing that,
which wasn't perhaps the most
conservative garb to dawn if you're
going to wear,
if you're going to go to a maximum
security prison.
So anyways,
I was in the gymnasium and the
psychologist,
the psychologist left and God only
knows.
I mean that's what he was like.
And all these guys came around.
All these guys came around me,
you know,
and they were offering to trade their
prison clothes for my cape and he was
like,
I was being made an offer I couldn't
refuse,
you know,
and so I didn't,
I didn't really know what to do.
And then this little guy said something
like that,
the psychologist sent me to come and
take you away or something like that.
And so I thought,
well better this little guy then all
these monsters.
So we went outside the gym through some
doors,
like school doors,
went outside the gym into the exercise
yard I guess,
and we're wandering along and he was
talking to me and he seemed like a kind
of an innocuous guy.
And then the psychologist showed up at
the door and motioned us back.
And so,
which was kind of a relief.
And so I went into his office and he
said,
you know,
that guy that you walked out in the yard
with?
And I said,
yeah.
He said he,
uh,
he took two cops one night and he had
them kneel down and while they were
begging for their lives,
he shot them both in the back of the
head.
And I thought,
hmm,
that's.
See the thing that was so interesting
was that he was so innocuous,
right?
Because what you'd hope is that someone
like that would be very much unlike you,
let's say,
and certainly wouldn't be like somewhat
innocuous that you'd met.
What you'd want is that the guy would be
like half world wolf and half vampire so
you could just tell right away that he
was a cold blooded killer.
But no,
he was this sort of ineffectual little
guy who was certainly not ineffectual if
you gave them a revolver and the upper
hand.
And so,
so that made me think that made me think
a lot about the relationship between
being innocuous and being dangerous.
And then another thing happened.
I met another guy out there and then a
week or two later I heard that he and a
friend of his had held another guy down
and pulverized his left leg with a lead
pipe,
like just pulverized it.
And the reason for that was that they
thought that he was a snitch and maybe
he was and that that time I did
something different and instead of being
shocked and horrified by that,
although I certainly was,
I thought,
how in the world could you do that?
Because I didn't think I could do that.
Hey,
I didn't think that.
I thought that there was a qualitative
distinction between me and those people.
And so I spent about two weeks trying to
see if I could figure out under what
conditions I could do that.
Like what kind of psychological
transformation I would have to undergo
to be able to do that.
And so that was a meditative exercise,
let's say.
And it only took about 10 days for me to
realize that not only could I do that,
that it would be a hell of a lot easier
than I thought it would be.
And that sort of where that wall between
me and what you described is the shadow
started to fall apart and that also was
very useful because I started to.
I started to treat myself as somewhat
different entity because I hadn't been
aware up to that point,
you know,
because I thought I was a good guy and
there's no reason for me to think that
because you're not a good guy unless you
really made a bloody effort to be a good
guy.
You're just not.
It's not easy and so you're probably a
moderately bad guy and that's a long
ways from being an absolutely horrible
guy,
but it's also a long ways from being a
good guy.
And so.
But I had a little more respect for
myself after that because I also
understood that there was a monstrous
element to the human psyche that,
that you needed to respect and that was
part of you.
That you should regard yourself in some
sense as a loaded weapon.
It's very useful around children to
regard yourself as a loaded weapon
because around children you are a loaded
weapon and the terrible experiences that
many children have with their parents
are testament to that.